dave i think we're live brother
okay cool i'm just talking first of all
how are you my friend
i'm doing good uh i i i'm just telling
our main account here to retweet this
from me uh i'm doing well it's been a
fun
fun word but rewarding week doing the
barcelo fun
so raising a lot of money helping a lot
of businesses and trying to get this
thing
bigger and you know the more money we
get the more business we save pretty
straightforward
yeah let's go into that so first of all
before we get into this little sunday
night chat
um i just want to uh wish everybody a
happy holiday like
for the people that are coming from my
community yes i was off the grid that
was the plan no social this week
and then our very handsome friend here
dave
uh tweeted out something i i saw it i
was in
transit actually um doing some family
stuff and
it was very easy for me to get involved
i've been kind of off the radar
between closing out the businesses and
uh
for the year and kind of setting up this
off the grid time but
i had seen a little something about this
but i wanted dave let's let's start this
conversation we're gonna
like i promised just now on uh the
people i just texted
um we'll do a little conversation about
a little small business and a little
sports because why not
some of the nfl stuff um we could talk
about the jets game that just said with
the browns we could talk about a million
different things which i think would be
fun because we've never really jammed
like this before
but for the main thing and dustin if you
can throw up the url right now i know
we've got it pinned
elsewhere for everybody's tuning in
right now
what i wanted to do was bring an
enormous amount of awareness
to this incredible initiative that the
bar you know
i'm so proud of the bar stool family i
even had to this beautiful hat i got the
other day from doing the sunday
conversation with he's a talent by the
way that was a fun interview to do yeah
he's amazing caleb
um so i decided to take bring it out
because it's just really fun to watch
people do
good things and i'm going to let you
take over the conversation dave tell
everybody who's
not aware what is the bar stool fund
uh and uh and a little origin story
about it and then we'll get into it
sure so you know it basically the
barcelona fund started
uh i don't know a week ago maybe 10 days
ago somewhere around there i've lost
track i think it's probably closer to
eight days
i went on a rant when new york city they
closed indoor dining and i essentially
said you know i don't know what the
state the city expects these people to
do the restaurant tours the bars
they've already been squeezed to the end
and they're trying basically
to do everything they can to stay open
they're being as creative as they can
whether it be creating the outdoor
structures the separation the air events
you name it they're doing it they're
trying to be so creative
but i don't know how anyone can survive
when you're not allowed to have
customers
and then the flip side is you're not
being given
you know any money really to help get
you through this so
it's a killer you can't earn a living
but the tax
bill is still coming so what are these
people supposed to do and i i ranted
about it
and a guy who i i really wasn't familiar
with marcus lemonis
basically tweeted at me he's like hey
loudmouth put your money where your
mouth is
so uh and he's like i'll donate if you
start a fund
and put 500k of your own money into it
i'll match it so i was like
all right my original take when he said
that there's a no-brainer i was like you
know i will put my money i've been
fortunate barcelo's successful
and then we spoke with marcus about it
because the reason i was like well
we're not charity like i i don't know
that we want to be touching all this
money and moving around and deciding
money was a simple thing we talked to
marcus and he works with uh
the the world central kitchen great
cause and um
but when barcelona does stuff and we
have a history of doing a lot of charity
over the years
um forever but when we do it we like to
generally control it and when i say
control it
have a direct say where the money is
going know how fast we can get it out so
erica and i sat and we came up with this
plan which essentially
we started with the 500 grand said we
want donations we joined with
a 501c the 30-day fund that was a big
the original my hesitation is like well
we're not charity so how are we going to
take money
and let people get write-offs and
whatever it may be and do it all
legally in the right way well we found
the 501c with the 30-day fund and
they're like we'll let you use our
engine
and you can do that whatever you want
with the money tell us where the money
goes we'll send it
so that was step one and then we came up
with this plan which is essentially
you needed to fill two requirements one
the business the small business we said
any small business who needs help
immediately contact us
the requirements being you have to prove
that you're a successful business
over the course hopefully at least a
couple years now
not everyone as you get stories there
are strange circumstances but
that's that's rule one because it's
basically
we wanted to say hey i've been running
this thing for 10 years my
family for 20 years and we've been
successful every year the only thing
that changes the pandemic
because then if we're giving money to
them the assumption is once the potemk's
gone they can get back to business as
usual
they're operators correct yes it's not a
concept
it's not a concept it's not something
that just which is
horribly bad luck that you just started
or something but it's like well
a lot of businesses fail so are we like
trying to get money to a business that
we have no idea
because that's great but there's a
million out there that are proven
successes
so you gotta you know you gotta pick and
choose your battles and number two we
won the payroll one
we wanted to see companies owners
that were basically still paying their
employees a lot of them telling these
stories like i've gone into my savings
my retirement
you know i'm mortgaging stuff those
speak to us all
to keep their employees paid and
fed and all that so if you met those two
requirements
from there it's just feel it's the story
it's the video that they provide with us
who's on the committee and by the way
everybody's watching or listening please
go to barstoolfun.com
um it's important you know so i'll jump
in we'll be a little help to skelter but
i was about to ask
who's making the judgment on feel is
that strictly you is that you and erica
is that a small little committee
yeah so we have like is led by uh liz
gonzalez
who from the second she's worked with us
has been huge into philanthropy worked
at charity before
but she's the initial line of defense
we've added more people going through
the emails
and there's so many of them and
unfortunately
so she goes through them some are just
discarded they don't provide the
information that we need so it's like
you know there's ten thousand
yeah there's ten thousand if you don't
come with what we're asking
it's tough um then she narrows it down
we get the videos
and then i get probably like 20 to 25 a
day
that i go through and then it's feel now
it's also
the money has been flowing pretty pretty
nicely so we haven't
had most of the ones that get to me i'm
like yup yup yup yup because
i'm banking on working continue to grow
get more donations
and we want the money out i'd rather run
out of money faster than sit on it
waiting for other companies
so this has been going on for a little
over a week yep
and if i'm looking at this correctly
dave you've raised
7.4 million dollars correct yep
7.4 million and i think over 60
000 people have donated so it's coming
from all angles individual five dollar
donations
67 almost 68 000 almost 70 000 people
have donated and by the way
for the vayner nation a lot of people in
my ecosystem you know
outside of what i did with the all in
challenge and
let's just i'm just gonna yeah so we
raised 59 million dollars
michael rubin from fanatics similar
agenda a human who wanted to do
something
i got very very involved in that one
same
you know i mean it's astonishing that
you've raised this much money dave it's
obviously hit
a huge accord and plus the community
that barstool has is just remarkable
i you know normally 97
89 of the time when this happens in my
life i do what i did
which was you know you you gave the
shout out
i dm'd you we had a phone call i
made a commitment but you know kind of
knowing that i had this sunday afternoon
and just knowing my community i actually
have an inbox email
uh from somebody who's matching my
donation from another company that i'm
working with
that's great and that's why i wanted to
do it and that's one of the things why i
reached out to you
so and another thing i've been doing and
i didn't do it to you because i
apologize dave i apologize so final
thought on that everybody's watching
right now
if you have the ability to support
the small businesses that i kind of kick
some tires and i love the way they're
going through this they're really
i think the dollars are going to the
right places the reason i'm so involved
in charity water and pennsylvania
promises
the money goes to the thing it's not the
30 percent of the money going through
infrastructure um if you're lucky enough
and
and this is really why we wanted not we
i and thank you for coming on dave what
i wanted to do was
really just give a shout out to my
community and saying hey if you can give
anything and especially this is rarely
where i'm at because i get a
thousand emails like this a month which
is the greatest gift of my life
if i've given you advice whether it's
sports cards or whether it's been social
media or tick tock
and you felt an economic impact if
you're in a place where you can give one
percent of that back
into the bar stool fund right now by
going to the website it would mean the
world to me
um i i just think doing the right thing
is always the right thing and so
please consider that if you can't then
that's remarkable i understand but i
want to bring awareness tonight as well
so go ahead my friend yeah and even i'd
echo what i think is
driving that and driving the money and
why you were just so passionately
the videos that we're putting out when
we call and tell these business owners
hey
the fun is going to be there and we tell
them which i i don't
think i said the first time we're not
just there for one month we're just not
there for two
we're gonna be there until the economy
opens up and you can run your business
because what is the point of giving
somebody
a check in one month and then you
disappear in month three and they're
right back in the same spot
when you're in trouble we lose the money
so we're we have this expanding payroll
basically now
so everyone who's in the fund they can
depend on us for that
nut we get all their tax so it's a lot
on our end like our finance with gia
shout out to her
she's getting their you know taxes
they're renting
you're really auditing this businesses
you're probably making a nine month
you know if i was part of team and say
hey let's project nine months because
you know i think that's best case
scenario september [ __ ] gets back to
normal
you know you're probably you're running
those numbers by the way hugo i see you
in the comments yes that was me just
sending the text
dave and i were doing our promotions
right before we went on that was my two
[ __ ] fingers brother
go ahead go ahead yeah yeah so uh so
that that's part of it and then if you
see this story if you watch
the videos in the reactions that like
there's some that stand out there's a
dry cleaner
i see you doing the facetimes right yes
yes so
[ __ ] crying and [ __ ] yes it's like
the move the bus
thing when they move the bus on that old
house show and they just
but they don't know i'm calling so it's
a little complicated because
facetime actually doesn't let you uh do
voice record
so i have another guy who stands behind
me i do it and then we merge the sound
together
but it's it's the most impactful
marketing
we can possibly have i mean these people
are breaking down and you see
the stress of these business owners dave
some people in the comments because i'm
reading along on all platforms thank you
everybody who's on twitch facebook all
the platforms
linkedin some people are saying they can
give any amount
is that correct any amount yes fantastic
amount what's uh uh you can actually get
more chocolate 24 you can give any
amount
i just want to again thank everybody
who's willing to give from the goodness
of their heart
dave what's up what stood out what have
you learned in a week and then by the
way i know a lot of people are asking
for us to do a little entertainment
we'll talk a little sports in a minute
i actually want to see where you are on
the sports card thing
because i've been dying to ask you about
that but anyway what what
what's what's stood out you know it it
the hardest part i think and it
shouldn't be surprising
is these small business owners really
don't want the money like they need it
but there's an element like i try my
best
no they don't want to feel like it's
charity they want to work
so i've done my best not to call this
like a charity like we're just helping
you
but they they they're running there is
an element of psychology
people have people i'm sorry to
interrupt have people
said i'm going to pay you back like that
yeah i get it listen i [ __ ] get bro
i don't want to owe anybody any like i
get like i understand that [ __ ]
yeah and there's an element like you're
taking my it's like i
i've been successful i'm running i
shouldn't like i shouldn't be here and
and it's to no fault of their own that
they are this is i'm [ __ ] president
this is um
[ __ ] once in every 100 years [ __ ] and
by the way one of the things that really
pulled at my heartstrings on this whole
thing and i've been doing some things
behind the scenes and why i really
jumped on your thing here
is it was a luck of the draw [ __ ]
game
yeah like you know like my dad i grew up
in a liquor store that
has done well right in this environment
it's geography i mean you can be you can
be 100 yards away from something in the
same business
we did a yoga that we gave to a yoga
studio
today and she's saying and it makes
sense she's like our people don't move
we put math six feet across they can
wear masks
and you can get on an airplane and by
the way on the record
i'm not government bashing either
because this is [ __ ] hard
right the whole thing is [ __ ] hard
the whole thing right sweden was [ __ ]
unstoppable right yeah they weren't like
[ __ ] hard the number one thing which
i agree and i think a
large degree the frustration is like
they're not being communicated with
they're like there's no plan
like what we're just sitting twiddling
in the wind and that's incredibly
frustrating
and and to me what really is interesting
about this and again
i felt the highs of this when i was
really scared in march and april for my
own [ __ ] businesses
but with reuben on all in challenge was
and then we live
in an internet world in a we you and i
live in a country that does have the
freedoms to just do [ __ ]
in comparison to other places in the
world here the [ __ ] we are too [ __ ]
got just sitting here
and you and your incredible team have
[ __ ] raised 7.5 [ __ ] million
dollars in 10 [ __ ] days
it's incredible it is it speaks to like
or you could just do [ __ ]
right and that that was essentially this
and that was marcus responds like all
right yeah
let's do something um and we you know i
wish we did earlier because there's so
many businesses that have already
gone you walk around new york city you
see boards up everywhere it's super
depressing
yeah what what else can we touch on and
then by the way everybody i see all your
comments if you want to ask questions
happy to answer or or ask dave the
questions
anything else that we want to give some
awareness and then let's talk a little
opening nba and a little late football a
little bit of the bar stool magic yeah
no i i think that that's about it if you
go to the bar still fun you can see the
stories if you go to my instagram
store presidente all the stories are
there everything
throw up his instagram and and twitter
and also
um throw up some of the i see the
donations coming in
i i think dustin if you can get crazy on
the ones and twos behind the scenes here
and throw up some of the people i love
them
to get a little exposure and a little
love um keep going dave i'm sorry no
that that's it just like i i watch the
stories and my guess is if you
if you take a couple minutes to look at
these people's reactions you'll donate
because you'll you'll feel it you'll
feel it in your bones
well listen i want to be before we segue
into some other content and we'll come
back to it at the end
i just want to thank you for you know
you know reaching out and and letting me
be a part of this
no i'm glad i mean you you were is the
internet's such a deep place i obviously
knew who you are you were the one of
most requested people the other people
someone i i didn't know mr beast was
mr beast dropped 150 grand in two
seconds and like i was on the phone with
him three seconds later
i didn't even i didn't know he was it's
crazy he sold seven trillion [ __ ]
burgers dude
i know i know he's telling me about it
it's pretty amazing
uh dave what uh what do you think about
what's your hot take uh give me some hot
sports takes on uh the beginning of the
nba season what what
stands out besides the fact that i think
20 minutes an hour ago i saw that the
mavs were beating this 20 years
yeah i don't know i'm not i'm a
traditional i don't really
nba it feels like it just ended you know
the pandemic so
jammed together uh and it's still
football to me is the only sport that
kind of works without fans where it
feels
sort of similar to a degree 100
if you watch the game i couldn't agree
with you more like it's
not so [ __ ] different right the nba
mlb those feel really different to me
without the crowds there's something off
with it
um but you know i'm curious i hate kyrie
i
i hate him so watch watching how
brooklyn does will be interesting to me
i i listen i think i think people are
completely confused
on how good of a basketball player kevin
durant is
i really do i think he's the best right
like i think that's the part that's been
most interesting for me i think people
you know with that kind of injury i get
it but like 3132
isn't 3132 how old are you dave i'm 43.
perfect so i'm 45 so like when we grew
up those ages because
these guys weren't working out like this
taking care of themselves you started
getting into those ages things happen
but
now yeah and they have
the the the surgeries and the
technologies and
the power i mean there's there's guys
bounce back in less than a year for
injuries like knee injuries that would
be career enders
correct what what's your super bowl
prediction right this half second
i'm going to say buffalo in the saints
i'm rooting for buffalo so as you know
gary i
am the preeminent patriot fan in the
world um
ironically bob and jonathan kraft called
me 10 minutes apart without knowing they
were calling me to donate this morning
they had no idea the other one called um
i love buffalo fans i love them
i love the city i hope for their sake
they can get there and i'm rooting for
the first time ever the patriots you
know they're not involved so i don't
have hate towards anybody else it's like
i'm just watching from the sidelines
so i'm rooting for buffalo and i think
they're pretty good i the chiefs i think
could be got yeah so i'm a little bit in
a different place than you
yeah you're in a funny laugh out loud
laugh at you please
i'm in a place where like i want to
punch
josh allen in the [ __ ] face like i i
said to my friend lou today i'm like you
know it's gonna be buffalo in tampa
and i'm not even gonna watch that
[ __ ] game like i'm in such a dog [ __ ]
place
all those years when buffalo and miami
were straight
dog [ __ ] dog [ __ ] but
it was the two decades to be dog [ __ ]
because it didn't matter
right that's for the second best team in
that division for all that time
it you weren't getting past new england
and so
now finally the [ __ ]
turntable turns finally tom's out of
there
finally there's a glimmer of something
and what happens
buffalo and [ __ ] miami are rising and
i'm in straight dog [ __ ] land
you know it is so [ __ ] being the jet
the knicks fan for the last 20 years
is like really [ __ ] interesting [ __ ]
yeah it's bad my you know one of my good
friends is the jets gm
joe douglas so the best i love joe so
[ __ ] much
like honestly the only thing that is
even making me
kind of like cool is i believe in joe
so much i'm devastated listen i
i i don't think you can even begin to
truly analyze sam darnold like
i i don't know what i it's not that i
wanted trevor lawrence
i wanted joe to have the option right to
be able to trade it for seven top 100
picks
if he wanted to continue down the
darnold path
but like i mean i'll be texting joe
every day starting
probably right after this call to trade
the second pick for a haul
because i think we have so many things
we have to build around yeah he's so he
went to school with one of my best
friends
uh richard yeah yeah richmond so i've
known him
forever like newport summers back you
know
college years i've known him forever
since his first job so
yeah i i i actually don't hate darnold i
i i don't think
i agree with you i don't think you can
evaluate him yet he's younger than joe
[ __ ] burrow the guy
baby yeah i've been so bad so
bad like you know it's tough anyway i'm
[ __ ] sick of that what about
so let's talk about something else what
do you think about all the exhibition
boxing what's your
take on all the stuff we're seeing in
the brilliant
so i bought a boxing league not like
that but we bought something called the
rough and rowdy
probably like four years this is a you
know if you talk to erica
about this about three and a half years
ago three years ago
she was in my office we were talking
about something else i actually think
what you did with that is actually the
seed and precursor to what we're seeing
i actually think bar stool
is not getting enough credit and not
that you're out there for credit or
things
it's always execution right right but
like those
pay-per-view numbers like like like i
would watch
nine hours of youtube videos of two
random [ __ ] guys
trying to punch each other bare knuck
kimba you know
the old kimbo and that's not what's his
name that's how the guy who's
uh muslim is one of those guys
right so like to me like i thought you
created the precursor in a lot of ways
to the pay-per-view
then the paul brothers have built on top
of it and now we're like
really in like real land and i think
it's like
really a [ __ ] thing it is and we
actually tried to get jake paul the
fight in rough and rowdy way back when
the i agree it's a thing and i think uh
jake paul's next fight is gonna be
enormous because of what he did in his
last one
where the bubble bursts is if people
start to be like well these guys can't
fight
like you know they're jake paul did the
best thing that you can do
for any fight game he created an entry
with
a spectacular knockout of a pro duran
yeah no listen listen i'm a big nade fan
and i like him as a human and he's a
nick and all that good stuff
but he's a real he's a real athlete i
thought he was gonna win i would have
bet on nate because of what you i was
like no this guy's an nba he can dunk
he's like
uh nba athlete what people are missing
is that the paul brothers are really
really spending a
[ __ ] load of time training yes like like
you know when when people saw that we
were on
they're like you two should fight for
charity and i was like man if we took
nine months to train we would be totally
different animals
than we are right now and both of us and
i again we don't
super duper know each other but from
everything i know of what you've created
and like how you navigate
we would both be so scared shitless to
lose
and have that video in perpetuity on the
internet like i would [ __ ] quit my
career
i'd just be too scared for that video to
loop and perpetua
i know i know i i would never agree to
fight anybody my shoulders would pop out
it'd be a disaster that's why i bought
the league but
yeah they're taking it seriously and we
you know i we had uh who's
absolutely i'm trying to play um my
favorite guy teddy teddy atlas
on talk about it and you know he says
the other guy's been in the ring he says
you can train you can do this his phrase
when the ninjas come over the wall
it's a different vehicle it's a
different beast or
mike tyson everybody's a play until you
get punched in the face so it's just a
different sport
and technique and all that but what he
did
is he created can this kid fight that's
what he just created
another thing is these people have real
audiences like the other
the other thing that i think is not
talked about enough is
brand nostalgia you look at tyson jones
do you know much money i would pay for
larry bird versus magic johnson
one on one right now dave yes i would
pay
50 pay-per-view to 21 one-on-one
give those guys six months to [ __ ]
shred it up get their [ __ ] together
i would be but that one-on-one or
dion how about dion versus bo jackson
in a race in a race because i've always
said this from a business standpoint
nostalgia
is wildly [ __ ] underpriced yeah i
agree with that
like to me like i'm i would beat
gaga on all day saturday on social and
have buddies over
bird magic one-on-one i think
i don't get ass like i didn't care about
the tyson fight and in a problem like
did you
know why because you knew it was an
exhibition it's the same reason
the same you knew that jake and nate
were fighting where
right whereas there's very different
rules i think that has the ability to
undermine
the mayweather logan paul fight you know
it's an exhibition it's different than
what jake and nate did
so so then you have to do you're right
on that because
even if you looked at like the tiger
versus phil that sucked because they
didn't care
and it was it's like they're joking
around
which is why i think the inter and you
know this this is the
i mean look both of our careers have
benefited from the deep
centralization of media the internet is
the middle man
you get anybody anybody
that has audience has intrigue you look
what jake's doing now like
yeah the way he's goading these four to
five other people right now is
[ __ ] intense yeah no right it's
brilliant
right how much is it is it show how much
is it not you know it's always a mix of
two but
here's what it comes down to for example
dave i am really [ __ ] good at bubble
hockey
yeah right yeah yeah i know it yeah
what's that yeah used to me you're
talking to russia usa with the boo
button
yes to me i think right now if we get a
little spicy here with each other
and get into a seven game [ __ ] series
on bubble hockey that's a [ __ ] load more
people than people would ever think
would [ __ ] watch that [ __ ] i agree
talking about caring
if i lose that [ __ ] i disappear and by
the way here come all the comments like
dave you got to do is get gary vee off
the [ __ ] world but like like to me i
punched the [ __ ]
like to your point if people care if two
people care about anything
darts fighting one-on-one bubble [ __ ]
hockey
if people care and their stakes you will
tune in and
and their stakes when people [ __ ]
walk right 100
people watch now you get into pride [ __ ]
money
[ __ ] promotion you get into [ __ ]
pride like
like nate do you i don't know how
educated people are about i know you are
nate robins is not only a real
basketball player he's one of the
great athletes the guy who won top
60 picks in the nfl draft like he's an
incredible athlete
that's why it was so stunning to me yes
and now what's his legacy it could be
him lying on the ground it's crazy
this is what really upsets me because i
love him so much to me
his legacy like that image is hard to
[ __ ] erase
yes the guy's won slam dunk contest he's
done incredible things
he's an incredible all-time guy and
athlete it hurts and i think that's what
goes into like
like i'm not kidding i don't know how
com you know i i assume like
i'm uncomfortably competitive like
having you
go like this and the whole barstool
mafia [ __ ] on me when you win
game six in bubble hockey is something i
can't live with which is why i would go
into that
[ __ ] scared and focused right yeah
listen i'm not gonna sit here like i
don't know how much bubble hawk you play
and that's the only reason i'm
restraining like
i don't play any i haven't played bubble
hockey in three years
but it's less about i'm actually talking
theory than
setting up a bubble hockey scene i
thought we were going out of bubble
hockey it's like i was already
arm wrestling right you think about all
these [ __ ] muscle heads
like the gram all looking jacked as [ __ ]
you get two people with five million
audience that [ __ ] arm wrestling
thing is gonna be [ __ ] crazy anything
i mean there's
obviously huge pressure and what he's
doing is brilliant i said
right when because i it was an
interesting reaction jake paul we had we
had him on and it wasn't really fair
because
ever like me i i said i said i think
you're going to lose
and then when he won everybody's like he
just beat it like an athlete
and people hate him in there and he
called out conor mcgregor and everyone's
like you're an [ __ ] why would you
call out carl mcgregor it's like because
he's brilliant
because then by the way i think he's
going to fight mcgregor eventually
because mcgregor is going to take a huge
fat
paycheck for not even having to risk
anything
but that's where it gets interesting
like you know to me risk anything right
so for example
logan paul is dramatically bigger than
him he is
i said i said i thought i thought
mayweather excuse me yeah i thought
mayweather versus
conor would be a bigger mismatch than
logan vs mcgregor because the size
difference i thought mayweather i was at
that fight
just toy he's like whenever i feel like
i can just put this guy away i can do it
um you're right he's way bigger
way bigger and like by the way let's
talk about what they're doing
they're doing fighting right what one
punch
boxing is right boxing versus the other
so i think that fight
now i've guessed dylan dannis is gonna
who's gonna be fighting next which is a
far
different fight than what he just did
but if he beats still and dennis
he's going to get one of the bigger
paydays in in
fighting he will i actually think that
this entire genre
can be incredible for boxing because if
you think about it
if you think about let's talk about
let's talk about um
joshua fury let's just talk about that
fight if the
three of the four under cards are
you know bob memory versus you
a [ __ ] you know like like i don't
even like my name being said in the same
sentence with that guy now that guy my
show is in pop out but go ahead
but i'm saying people that are popping
right people that are popping it
you look at what dwyane wade's like
culturally relevant like
you know if wayne wade decides to but
you know like
box a former basketball tracy mcgregor
like the undercards
of actual big boxing events yeah i mean
you change the pay-per-view numbers
dramatically big time
big time it's an interesting thing on a
lot of levels because i could see people
saying it's horrific for boxing on the
other side because the true uh
purists for the game you know these guys
are in gyms making nothing sweating away
and you see a guy
that is basically now getting the
biggest paydays in the game and he's not
a real boxer they say
i could see how that would be extremely
frustrating for
somebody in it dave they also said
hip-hop wasn't real music when you and i
were kids
yeah that's true no i mean like cool
they told me that internet businesses
weren't real businesses
literally my [ __ ] face when i was 19
internet businesses aren't real business
like i don't give a [ __ ] what [ __ ]
people said is real or isn't the
consumer decides
correct but there is an element
of this is supposed to be a sport
where the it's sport versus
entertainment sport versus
entertainment business there's people
that say golf isn't a real sport you
know this it's a huge debate
right but again it's like almost
like an anna kournikova like tennis like
she never wins but she's getting the
most money because she's gorgeous
but it's like people will be mad like
well she's not one of these events
getting the most money off the court
correct she's also a top 25 player
during that era
yes but it is that dynamic like if
listen if i was sweating
my ass off in the gym with no followers
and i know i can go beat him
easily and i see him get all the
headlines on my i'd be
furious you spent a decade building an
audience
oh yes but not through boxing people
think that you're [ __ ] this isn't
like i laugh at people when they talk
about this i'm like yeah right no i
didn't
like that but every 15 to 25 year old
giving a [ __ ]
i'm sorry that you feel you made a nice
print magazine around the sport
like [ __ ] you like the consumer decides
now on the flip side
i'll go watch i'll watch the i'll watch
the canelo fight
and love the defense and like like i i
like both are super fascinating to me
like i'm actually a humongous boxing fan
and i actually love defensive fighters
everybody hates them because i'm
fascinated i mean purnell whitaker was
my favorite fighter growing up
oof sweepy i mean to me i just was
fascinated by his ability to have that
kind of defense and then obviously
mayweather became
the 3.0 version of that but that doesn't
take away the fact that my juices are
going to be going
the next time there's a celebrity
influencer fight that i just think is
funny and interesting or 100
100 and to be honest they have the
version of it they had the celebrity
boxing a while back which isn't
the right people because they didn't
have these huge audiences
fox how to get you to give a [ __ ] about
screech correct
they were the paul brothers the
mcgregors
or the like these people were in their
prime of it
isn't there if dan blizzarian who's been
i guess
feels a little quieter than three years
ago but if he decides to if i hear
tomorrow
blizzarians fighting steve aoki i'm
[ __ ] watching
right yeah and and the paul brothers are
masters
of the internet i mean you really can't
deny that so they have the huge
followings and they get it
he gets it when we talk to him it's like
who's your next fight going to be
whoever i can make the most money who i
think have the best chance to win he's
not looking
for king kong he's looking for the most
interesting fight
that will allow him to get the next
fight and for me
people spend 30 40 dollars to escape
we're in the middle of a global pandemic
right so for me that fight that they
promote and create an
intrigue on is no different than
watching that
incredible jamie foxx movie on disney
plus that just came out seoul
or watching wonder woman on hbo max
it's no different than watching sports i
love people that are like this is
[ __ ] stupid why do people spend money
on this i'm like
you spent money on the nba league pass
like there's a lot of people
give a [ __ ] about the nba like why is
luca throwing a ball in a basket
so much greater like people are allowed
to have their escapism
the market determines what the market is
i mean they wouldn't be doing it if they
weren't selling all the pay-per-views
dave i wanted to ask you this is why i
text you back after our call but we
we we both have family stuff have you
seen the sports card thing has that hit
your radar now that you have
to know that you're 43 it means you
lived through
yeah oh i i have i have i thought i was
going to retire on
phil plans here rookie cards no bro you
were more of a mike [ __ ] greenwell
than ellis burns
listen phil plantier in his stance he
hit
72 home runs at all-star break his
rookie year
right he was a padre my friend brandon
warnock he brandon warren
big shout out he bought so many [ __ ]
phil plantier rookie cards
i had phil plant here and juan gonzalez
and those are my two guys
i was huge on greg vaughan and kenny
lofton
i did well my two guys kind of panned
out a little bit and
then there was the ones everyone had the
greg jeffries the ricky jordans
kevin moss was [ __ ] in that one year
yeah
when you when you when you first
beg when you first heard this this has
all been happening last two and a half
three years
didn't you say like that's going to be a
quick fad one month yeah i i
still don't know much about it i lived
through the earlier one
like crashed with beckett's so i
understand i see what's going on
but i am very i am not what about wise
to it
what about this you know to me it's
funny three years ago when i started
talking about this
i was like you know you start thinking
about who and what
you know it's interesting i feel like
almost nobody does the current
pulse of the culture of sports and youth
like this right kudos to you i've never
been able to say that to you actually
quickly passing in a next game i said it
to you but i really believe it
and i have a lot of respect for it i
actually think you
i actually think the organization the
company has incredible permission to be
a major player in it
so i know it's something we're looking
at and we're aware
very much so like eric is involved in it
we're having
different companies so it is something
that
has been percolating now i would say for
six months to a year within our company
like all right what are we doing in this
space
me personally i haven't been on the
forefront of it
i get it i get it what about wrestling
we have a lot of people who love
wrestling and i grew up in wrestling
no no you never liked wrestling oh no
yes yes not now
yeah all right ready top three wrestlers
of all time uh start with number three
i'm gonna give you a few minutes here
i'm gonna scan the comments and thank
everybody
while everybody's here we've been
yapping down below bar stool fund we
started the program with you if you're
just joining us
dave here incredible initiative decided
[ __ ] this [ __ ] we're gonna help
small businesses
literally in a [ __ ] weekend and a
half has raised 7.4 let me see if this
updates it doesn't yep 7.48
almost 7.5 million dollars kind of
shouted me out and he was exactly right
this seems to be up garyvee's ali it's
true i
like so i love doing gofundmes out of
nowhere for small businesses it's
where i come from i kind of made a
commitment behind the scenes
i also then wanted to jam tonight and
just bring a little awareness
r.i.p phil negro i see that that's a
great call that's our era
but we've been just yapping and kind of
entertaining a little bit here about
sports which i'm having fun with
i'm giving dave a few minutes to think
through because it's an incredibly
important question
yeah i don't know if i'm allowed to do
this but i have two sets of answers
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna play with you
here tell me before don't answer
anything
by the way the person who just said
bushwhackers [ __ ] got me fired up
but um what do you
explain to me
you're 43 which means you're in pocket
for the hogan era
and you're in pocket for yes like you're
perfect for this question
yeah take a second are they my favorites
these are your favorite top three
wrestlers okay
you don't have to you don't have to win
a debate on maryland
your top three favorite wrestlers of all
time
let's go with number three yeah yeah
this is a ridiculous answer but he made
me laugh every time he got the ring is
iron mike sharp
i love it mike and he always lost
like a thing but he never won you
remember k9
and barry horowitz they were all the
same [ __ ] guys they would lose all
right beautiful
dave honestly we're getting to know each
other here
one that has built a lot of equity with
me iron [ __ ] mike shark
remember iron mike
great answer beautiful number two i love
junkyard dog he loved junkyard dog
you loved the [ __ ] shane yes and
i loved his entrance music another one
bites the dust i loved his entrance
music
remember when he was on his little fours
that he would headbutt yup no
he would he was the best and then i
guess i gotta do this
because it was my so when i wrestle it
was my finishing move
it was like the only one i could do i
was my friends
like my friends when we were like just
because the camel clutch everyone can do
everything nope honky tonk man shake
rattle and roll
it's an easy one to do and roll them
over
were you devastated in summerslam
when the ultimate warrior beat the honky
tonk man and took the title
no because i just like doing the move i
love the warrior i love the warrior
so i'll still go back and watch his
speeches
every once in a while just to like rip
just to like laugh so he so he
was a wrestler that would make you upset
if they lost because you actually loved
them
for a moment i mean i i was a hoaxer guy
i mean you know and when he
one of the great i mean when he came
back
as with nwo and all that was insane
spectacular
do you know that that was a japanese
wrestling storyline bishop did a great
job with interpreting like that
that wasn't enough all right and you
know who my number one is everything
in the whole thing like i tend to
i love me and gene i love bobby the
brain like those guys
are so brilliant like some of the best
comedians
who ever lived 100 100
really like the stuff they say man i
i was so i was such a big randy the
macho man savage fan
and when i i got to the age where i knew
he was going to lose to hogan and
wrestlemania and lose the title
and i like for i was depressed for the
whole week
i still use so pen bought us when penn's
thought goes up
i'll put a ric flair clip that like
i'm the dirtiest player in the game like
i'm never gonna stop getting out of that
i'll do that
and when everyone's doubting me and we
end up being wrong
i it's it's uh who is this bobby the
brain
mr perfect mr perfect vignette of when
he's always perfect one of my favorite
ones
he throws the pass catches it in that
80s era
the way they would hike by the time
razor ramon by the time mr perfect by
the time
zeus would be in the ring you were so
jacked yes yes they did such
a great job of like the because we had
saturday morning and they did
yes and here they would come and i was
so hardcore wrestling i knew that other
guys were in different leagues and
yeah it was huge for me the million
dollar man he made the kids do the
push-ups saying like just knock them off
from the last one
he was great there's a lot of great
there was a lot of i'm i'm tuned
i got back in i gotta take care of
something i don't know what's going on
my door
can you give can we go take a step back
we'll come with a little more talk but
can you one more time for the people
that just joined
a little more awareness the bar stool
fund and ask for maybe people get
involved i'll be back in 20 seconds
yeah bar still fun donate we're raising
money for small business
he's out i'm in miami so i go shower and
people coming over so i know how long
this thing's going on for like
six hours but in the meantime
donate barcelona.com you follow it along
you know on my instagram school
president i go in barcelona sports you
see all the companies we're donating to
and the stories
i just gave a little tip that you don't
know gary which is i'm in miami and i'm
going out so i don't have all night
oh right so you can't we're not doing
this for nine hours correct that's what
i said
i'll let you go in a minute let's let's
let's talk about a couple other things
80 style favorite cartoon growing up
scooby-doo period do you remember
laughing yeah joe
what about laugh olympics no no never
saw it never heard of it
it was on usa and it was like the scooby
doobies versus the yahoo
yogi yahooys it was like a 1970s cartoon
but they
great papers in it they [ __ ]
re-programmed it for us
no no idea what that is oh takes punky
brewster
what about her hot no i don't know
whatever you want to say
she was like dad i had a crush on punky
brewster huggy brewster
or kelly kapowski oh well you're at
different
you don't even know where your privates
are during the punky brewster era during
the kelly kapowski
you know let's go in the middle winnie
cooper
well you got an mfk here so it's like i
i
i kelly kapowski is like the sexiest
yeah and winnie cooper you want to marry
i understand
what about he-man we're big on it
who boss man remember he was all like
moss what about stink or remember his
action figure smelled
yes i vaguely remember those i had i had
a bunch of those i had uh
the the the transformers i was big with
dinobots um
the last time you cried because of a
sports loss
i'll give you mine while you're thinking
game six red sox
bill buckner you cried yeah of course
you were [ __ ] young yeah yeah it's
hard to cry gary while my team's
win like every year actually that's a
good segue
let's play a little bit so last time you
cried was bill buckner game six which
makes a ton of sense you were nine i
think
yeah if i got my math yeah uh
yes correct so so
that makes a ton of sense i can't even
fathom that literally [ __ ] fathom
that
um the last time i cried was week one
of the week week one this is crazy week
one
of the 97 98 or 98 season when the jets
lost to the 49ers
when garrison hearst had a 98 yard run
in overtime because i was so convinced
that that was going to be our squad
and i literally cried i was 22 [ __ ]
years old i have
a video people who know me i'm gonna
call [ __ ] on this because there's a
video that patriots lost to the chiefs
in new england
um and i was at the game it was a
regular season game and it was in the
midst of our like
dynasty and i was having an allergic
reaction
when you guys got blown the [ __ ] out no
it was in new england it was
when goodell was there with the towels
was that the game when
when we lost that game but we lost in
kansas city
when when everyone's like the dynasty's
dead
um but i was having an allergic reaction
so it looked like i was crying so i just
took my camera and made a phone and
seemed like i was crying everyone's like
oh it's a regular season game
you're 43 years old as a boston fan i
have a really interesting question
so i actually genuinely enjoy the
process of trying to win
like it's fun for me i'm sure yeah
really do you
to your point and and and what an
incredible
run it's been for boston sports over the
last two decades
is it do you feel like when you were
chasing it as a kid because there was so
much
you know so much bad luck and you had
you had
sad things happen louis death
like you know there was i mean i
remember when the pats were 1 and 15 and
the only win was against the jack
you know you lost the super bowl to
green bay like
did is it different now that you won all
the rings like like is it diff
it has to be i think the red sox is
different um the patriots
what's that your store yeah yeah that
that the
that the chase was almost as fun when
you catch the girls like and they want a
bunch
the patriots are different and i'm most
closely associated with them
and i have a rivalry with the
commissioner all that jazz but the
patriots
dynasty has never been smooth in the
sense
everyone hates them so much so and
there's so much you cheated you did this
you did that
us against the world [ __ ] every year
it's like we're gonna say
[ __ ] you to you and we're gonna come do
it again um like even the last time they
won the super bowl with brady
and uh you know gronk and they make the
video with the bad boys like playing
behind it that you probably puked
but it was like still here like that i
loved it's like i love
being in america's face i haven't
watched the last four super bowls that
the patriots have been in
i don't even know anything about that
falcons game it's it was the
one of the great decisions of my life
was realizing
wait a minute if you don't see it you
don't
feel it the same way yeah so i'm the
polar opposite i was at the falcons game
i was at the
marshawn lynch one yard interception i
was at the
the interception game the malcolm butler
i was slumped in my seat because
you have mixed fans and the game was
over if they ran the ball and then the
interception i
threw my cell phone i just threw it and
i had to crawl through like popcorn and
stuff
like 20 rows up in an empty stadium to
find it after the thing was done
what about boxing real quick i'm going
to let you go in a second real quick
actually for everybody's listening
i know a lot of my community uh is on
here because i'm screaming on my
platforms couple things
this bar stool fund really hit me like
really hit me here i've i
i i'm a huge fan of erica the the ceo
of bar stool i've known her a long time
um i admire so much of what
what this man who's with me dave and
that coal crew like
kfc and [ __ ] cat and like the whole
thing is just
great execution just a lot of admiration
for winners that win and the media
execution i know
plenty of people have their opinions
about bar stool but just the execution
is
i'm impressed um
but what you're doing with this bar
stool fund is a real big deal you're
really [ __ ] helping people i see
comments in here like razzing me razzing
you and i'm like
this man's helping people right we
raised almost eight million dollars
in less than two weeks that are going
directly to businesses who literally
literally literally literally
potentially would be going out of
business
after spending their blood sweat and
tears for decades sometimes
into a business on something that you
can't control
and the fact that from the goodness of
heart and hard work to build the
audience you've built you've been able
to create this event it's incredible so
two things
for evidence listening one if you are a
business
that has been hit very hard by the
pandemic and you still are have your
payroll active and if you go to bar
stool fund i'm sure they'll teach you
how to apply please everybody who's part
of my community if you're a business
that could benefit from this
especially since i'm putting personal
money and i would knowing some of those
pennies or dollars are going to you is
huge for me please do that
everybody else who's watching if if
you're fortunate enough
to be in a place in your life where even
if you give fifty dollars
if you go to barstoolfund.com right now
like that actually is gonna help
somebody in a real real real real way
and by the way i i i'm on a lot of
nonprofits as most of you that follow me
know i'm not very loud about
the good things i do i i don't think
guilting
is fair nobody knows what's going on
behind somebody's door
so many of you are going through tons of
things many of you
want to give your hard-earned money to
things other than small businesses that
here
pandemic and that's incredible and i
love you for that and many of you don't
want to give and that's
[ __ ] it's america or wherever you are
in the world it's your choice however
if you're interested if you're being
entertained right now listen that's
incredible mostly i can get 50
that matters melissa that actually
[ __ ] matters so just
i just want to uh say that again and
dave thank you so much
55 55 thank you jennifer um i want to
thank you for tagging me uh yesterday it
really gave me a boost
a big thing yeah no i i appreciate you
having me on and just spreading the word
and it is it's a great cause
uh it's a needed cause and if you go to
the barcelona fund page you can figure
it out and if you go to barstool my
socials you'll see all the stories and
you'll you'll see why it's an important
cause
it's right out in front of you dave
i'm what's in store for barstool just
like
for five minutes i'm just i'm gonna let
you go because it sounds like you want
to hit the town hard in miami and
you know probably break all the rules
and get the bid and all that
you've already had twice i think uh yeah
so we're foot you know
it's crazy because we sold obviously the
company to a casino group maybe not
obviously but penn national
i got my we even sell the hats on the
great marketing i got people wearing our
stock symbols around
but um so yeah is that a spec
no nope um it's been crazy
it's talking 26 when uh they did the
acquisition went to 40 corona hit it
went to four and it's at 95
right now all in the span of a year it's
been crazy so
but you know the casinos were shut down
they're opening so we're supposed to be
launching the sports book sports
gambling is legal
so as states legalize it my focus will
be getting our audience our crowd
playing with us so that's a huge focus
of ours it's funny do you know one of
the biggest reasons i thought sports
cards would come back three years ago
was because of gambling
like why well it's another form
of gambling oh yeah yes absolutely in a
real meaningful way i mean the numbers
have been staggering
in that world and it's i i really it's
funny i'm really fascinated by betting i
think
it reminds me of alcohol in moderation i
think it's an
incredible additive to the experience
and i
i really you know obviously me and you
growing up on the east coast and towns
we grew up in in those eras we know a
bunch of generates that have gotten
themselves [ __ ] up
but anything in life comes to balance um
legalized vice i mean it's alcohol it's
gambling weed now
um you know that's what it is um
pizza is a big thing in your life i'm
gonna let you guys
a bunch of people like you two need to
do a pizza and wine thing i think that's
actually a fun idea
yeah pizza may be like the number one
thing people know me by
yeah you really hit like a a a moment
there it felt like about 18 months ago
i'm trying to remember when it hit
myself
we do it i do it every day i eat pizza
on the site almost every single day
uh the pizza community includes me you
rate it yeah rate it
and i've been doing it now for like five
years straight five years
what's the highest rated pizza of all
time uh the two that stick out
sally's in new haven new haven
connecticut's the piece of capital of
the world
period is that true yeah i mean in one
man's opinion or is that like
wildly like a big thing like [ __ ] new
haven connecticut's
big they they're very aware of it
there's like books and movies about it
but it is
they're all close it's a certain style
so you're frank pepe's
you have sal frank pepe's and sally's
you can throw a baseball one or the
other
modern um it's like it's like a chili
it's like the chili it's like the
philly cheesesteak thing yes i would say
that's fair
yeah and then new york i like john's a
bleeker
someone just said connecticut and york
it's new haven connecticut it's that
area it's not all connecticut
and new york has great pizza they have
the most of it there's a billion there's
a lot of bad beats in new york too
if kraft moved the team to hartford or
whatever the [ __ ] he was talking about
moving him to
way back when when he first spotted him
do you think you'd be a patriots fan or
you'd have been pissed
and by the no by the way you're 43 i'm a
little bit pissed about this [ __ ]
buffalo thing you just said they [ __ ]
dominated our division in your youth and
[ __ ] on you yeah but
it didn't matter the patriots were so
bad it wasn't
like it does matter no it won't matter
respect respect i [ __ ] i want to
punch thurman thomas in the throat
the patriots were the worst like
franchise of
all time so they were just laughing
stocks so it sucked
but it didn't matter if it was the bills
it didn't matter for the 49ers it didn't
matter if it was the cowboys like yeah
the patriots aren't going to beat these
guys
now like that's your division yeah but
if it wasn't like what you have this
angst that i can see in your face with
you know
parcells and belichick and spygate
there's that history together that
didn't exist with the bills
other than they [ __ ] on you for like 30
you lost 30 games in a row yeah but we
lost everybody
we were terrible all right gary i'm
going out
what are you going to do tonight i need
full details like there's a
place called can you live vicariously
through your [ __ ] on the river
i've never been it's a big sunday night
spot so i'm supposed to be meeting peop
i haven't showered and i'm a disaster
and i'm meeting people in 45 minutes i
hope you have a really good time happy
new year
thank you thank you for stepping up and
doing this for small businesses
i'll hit you up i've got more things i
want to do uh i have a in the whole
vaynerx world we have a small agency
called
the sasha group which i do for small
businesses i named it after my dad
uh i'm gonna talk to the president of
that company we're gonna do something in
addition to what i did personally with
you over the phone
and i just i wish you continued success
with this and i hope you have a great
new year's
thank you i appreciate you too take care
bye